mon métier c'est l'accélération je
travaille dans une industrie où tout va
très vite là
jeux vidéo qui à la frontière des
révolutions technologiques et du
renouvellement permanent des usages des
consommateurs et de son contexte
mon rôle c'est d'anticiper le futur de
fer que l'organisation apprennent encore
plus vite pour innover encore plus vite
autant vous dire que je [ __ ] à toute
vitesse en plus j'ai un enjeu il faut
que j'embarque dans ma roue les
personnes de l'organisation parce que
innover c'est avant tout un processus
social en 2013
je tombe de mon vélo supersonique
je me sens fatigué frustré j'ai
l'impression qu'en dépit de tous mes
efforts les choses n'avancent pas que je
n'arrive pas à faire changer
l'organisation
alors j'ai une idée originale
je vais me former au coaching peut-être
que si j'apprends les compétences
nécessaires pour accompagner le
changement auprès des individus alors je
saurais le faire pour une personne et je
serais bien passé à l'échelle de
l'organisation
l'histoire que je vais vous raconter
maintenant c'est mon histoire et les
enseignements que j'en ai tiré sur la
meilleure façon d'engager le changement
dans une organisation
alors bien sûr il ya des choses que je
faisais déjà et que je pratique
désormais plus délibérément mais j'ai
découvert la puissance de la proche
paradoxal l'approchent paradoxal c'est
en fait ce que j'ai appris c'est que
quand on veut essayer de faire changer
les autres il est souvent bien plus
utile de changer de posture de changer
de regard de modifier ses façons de
faire de trouver d'autres façons
d'exercer son leadership des façons qui
bien souvent s'oppose aux manières de
faire habituelle et au discours ambiant
par exemple je croyais qu un bon leader
devait planifier et prévoir donner de la
visibilité
facile à dire mais pas facile à faire
dans un monde où le changement est
permanent et on doit jongler avec
l'imprévisible et l'incertain en 2016
par exemple je décide de faire pivoter
mon labo d'innovation j'ai une intuition
et une envie forte je me dis que si nous
pour expérimenter par nous-mêmes
construire un réseau d'experts externes
avec lesquels proposer des preuves
tangibles et concrètes de ce que nous
avançons alors peut-être que nous aurons
plus d'impact
il me reste à embarquer mon équipe dans
cette aventure
alors certains n'y ont pas cru et sont
partis d'autres n'arrête pas de
challenge et en me disant c'est pas
clair ton truc là il faut savoir faire
preuve d'humilité
accepter de ne pas savoir de ne pas
avoir toutes les réponses de
persévérance aussi pour rebondir au delà
des obstacles et réajuster le cap quand
on navigue en pleine incertitude
bien sûr il faut donner un cap
transmettre de l'énergie de l'
enthousiasme quelques points d'ancrage
nécessaires comme la frugalité par
exemple qui est bien précieuse pour nous
quand il s'agit de cadres et nos
partenariats ou nos expérimentations
mais il faut se garder d' un plan trop
détaillée qui nous empêcherait de saisir
les opportunités où les surprises qui
peuvent se présenter
par exemple en quelques mois je reçois
la candidature d'une ancienne d'ubisoft
qui revenait de plus de 10 ans de
production de jeux en chine elle
rentrait à paris j'avais trouvé la tête
de ma cellule de prototypage on me
propose aussi de quitter le siège pour
investir de nouveaux locaux dans
montreuil un atelier au fond d'une cour
alors certes nous y perdons en proximité
avec les équipes sièges mais nous
investissons un lieu ouvert plus riches
en mètres carrés modulable et dans
lequel nous pouvons organiser des
événements et accueillir des visiteurs
notre aventure peut commencer parce que
la meilleure façon de vérifier ses
intuitions c'est de passer à l'action de
les confronter au réel et en matière
d'innovation et de transformation
les analyses de risques détaillés les
calculs de héros y sont bien difficiles
à réaliser nous n'avons pas les
premières données du futur qui nous
permettrait de le faire alors il faut y
aller frugalement bien sûr pour limiter
la 4 lacasse connaître
son risque et itérer de manière
régulière
pas à pas nous commençons donc par
prototype et sur de nouvelles
technologies comme la réalité augmentée
les interfaces gestuelles et là on se
découvre un langage commun avec les
équipes de production
nous pouvons enfin avoir des discussions
sur des preuves tangibles concrètes
c'est bien plus efficace que nos
powerpoint il ya un deuxième avantage à
ce passage à l'action cet avantage c'est
la possibilité d'affiner notre vision
d'améliorer nos recommandations canton
prototype sur des technologies nouvelles
on peut juger beaucoup plus concrètement
de leur maturité
on peut aussi récupérer du feedback
utilisateurs bien précieux nous testons
aussi sur nous mêmes de nouvelles
théories organisationnel vanté dans tous
les ouvrages de management et là on
passe du mythe à la réalité
certaines sont vraiment des usines à gaz
d'autres remplace la flexibilité des
hommes par la rigidité des process je ne
suis pas sûre qu'on y gagne au change
par contre au passage cela permet à
l'équipe d'acquérir des dynamiques
collectives fondamentales comme celle de
s'écouter lors d'un tour de table est de
savoir se taire ça paraît évident mais
c'est très compliqué passer à l'action
c'est la meilleure façon d' inventer le
futur de construire par essai erreur sur
le socle de nos apprentissages et pour
cela nous pouvons aussi profiter des
expériences que d'autres ont mené de
leur succès mais surtout de leur échec
nous montons par exemple un programme
d'accompagnement de start up à station
avec l'incubateur parisiens pendant six
mois les experts d'ubisoft vont partager
leur expertise leur savoir faire avec
des start up qui elles sont en train
d'opérer rationaliser les nouveaux
métiers dans lesquels nous voulons
rentrer et la bloque chain
l'intelligence artificielle
les hologrammes c'est du vrai donnant
donnant chacun apprend de l'autre et nos
experts repartent dans leur équipe
enthousiasmés par ces nouvelles
technologies nous organisons aussi des
hackaton
alors ça c'est un moyen génial en moins
de 48 heures de développer et de tester
plein de nouvelles idées et surtout nous
y faisons la rencontre d'experts de
mentors passionnés de participants qui
sont bien plus avancés que nous sur ces
nouvelles technologies
innover c'est apporter quelque chose de
nouveau c'est prendre une idée quelque
part et l'amener autre part c'est au
coeur de notre métier
olabe nous regardons tout ce qui se
passe en dehors de l'industrie et nous
leur amenons dans notre industrie pour
en imaginer les impacts lablaude chain
par exemple quel impact ça peut avoir
sur l'expérience du joueur
en quoi ça peut nous permettre
d'améliorer nos processus internes
quel éclairage ça nous donne sur les
organisations véritablement innovantes
mais une idée elle est forcément un
carnet elle est portée par un individu
pour qu'il y ait échange d'idées il faut
qu'il y ait des interactions et ça c'est
la première responsabilité du leader de
l'innovation saturé qu'il ya de la
diversité la promouvoir la protéger je
ne sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué mais
les conversations sont toujours beaucoup
plus riches quand on a des profils des
expériences différentes
c'est là je trouve qu on touche du doigt
les sens de l'intelligence collective
alors je vous laisse imaginer les
conversations au lab entre mon
responsable blog shane qui est aussi un
ancien professeur de philosophie maîtres
de jeu de rôle le week end mon
programmeurs qui fait aussi du cinéma
des courts métrages et deux métrages et
le technical artistes un métier qui est
à la frontière du dessin et la
programmation mais qui aussi magicien
guitariste et qui donne des cours
d'anatomie lé dimanche à des profils
hyper spécialisés j'ai tendance à
privilégier des profils plus protéiforme
qui cherche à relier des choses entre
elles pour leur donner du sens
aujourd'hui nous vivons à l'heure de
l'intelligence artificielle et les
algorithmes peuvent facilement nous
enfermer dans nos modèles du monde dans
nos façons de voir limitant d'autant nos
choix une créativité et par rapport à
cela il me paraît urgent de développer
notre caution de curiosité et de
résister aux sirènes ambiante de la
rationalisation et la standardisation
quand on crée un contexte d' écoute de
bienveillance dans lequel chacun peut
exprimer sa singularité bien sûr on
amplifie les différences mais c'est dans
cette diversité cognitives qu'on peut
trouver la différence qui fait la
différence
en fait il ya un graal le un plus un
égale trois c'est l'art de la
conversation vous savez au sens d des
philosophes grecs
cette capacité à rentrer dans le conflit
à s'opposer et en sortir par le haut en
trouvant une solution nouvelle et
générative il nous permet d'intégrer nos
différences
l'ours a gelé vécu sur mon prototype
bloc chain mon porteur de projet avait
une idée assez claire décade usage assez
classique qui voulaient prototype et
l'équipe de prototypage elle voulait
aller beaucoup plus loin dans
l'exploration de cette technologie
révolutionnaire alors ils ont débattu et
changé et ils sont arrivés à la
différence qui fait la différence pour
la bloque chain cette différence est la
notion de puissance distribué chaque
ordinateur est un noeud du réseau et
l'ensemble des éléments apportent
davantage de valeur au tout et c'est là
qu'ils ont trouvé la bonne idée chaque
joueur va pouvoir générer sur son
ordinateur de manière procédurales c'est
à dire en utilisant l'intelligence
artificielle et la puissance de calcul
de son ordinateur une île la sienne elle
et c'est vraiment la sienne mais il peut
la mettre à disposition de tous les
autres joueurs en utilisant la
technologie blog shane une belle
métaphore du un plus un égale 3 alors il
ya un proverbe chinois que j'adore qui
dit que ce n'est pas en tirant sur les
plantes qu'on les fait poussé et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'en faire plusieurs fois
même l'expérience à chaque fois que j'ai
essayé de pousser des idées en force de
les passer en force
j'ai vu des murs se dresser devant moi
j'ai notamment le souvenir d'un modèle
qu'on avait développé pour nos équipes
créatives basé sur les modeler
motivation des joueurs
alors on avait trouvé un super modèle on
en parle à tout le monde on fait plein
de présentation et la plus on pousse
moins ça marche on se fait même
descendre en flèche par un directeur
créatif sur le réseau social de
l'entreprise qui explique que notre
modèle est nul et qu'il a bien mieux à
proposer
qu'à cela ne tienne nous le contact on
nous épousons ces propositions après
tout le modèle on s'en fiche ce qui
compte c'est les motivations des joueurs
et nous le propulse ont même à la tête
de la task force en charge de diffuser
ce nouveau process
c'est un bien meilleur ambassadeur que
nous ils ramènent derrière lui plein de
projets et on a gagné un effet boule de
neige
en fait en matière d'innovation et de
transformation
il vaut mieux oublier la bonne vieille
logique occidentale du quand on veut on
peut
et passer à une logique qui est plutôt
axé sur l'émergence créer les bonnes
conditions pour faire émerger les choses
en fait de paysagistes on devient
jardinier on sème des graines des
nouvelles idées des nouvelles méthodes
on apporte de l'eau de l'engrais des
experts des ressources supplémentaires
de la lumière c'est à dire de la
visibilité sur ses initiatives et
surtout on laisse faire parce que
finalement la meilleure chose qui puisse
nous arriver c'est que quelqu'un quelque
part sans part de l'une de nos idées il
emmène bien plus loin que ce que nous
pourrions faire
en fait c'est comme avec les enfants moi
j'ai trois ados à la maison et c'est
vrai que souvent on a tendance à se
comporter en grand sachant qu'ils
donnent des conseils
ça marche plus ou moins bien souvent il
vaut mieux créer les conditions de
l'expérience en limitant le risque et
laisser les enfants ont tiré les
enseignements par eux mêmes c'est
carrément plus durable quand on veut
devenir un bon jardinier exploiter le
potentiel des situations il faut des
renoncements nécessaire lâché légaux et
lâché prise
on est loin des notions d' exécution de
la stratégie à tout prix et
d'implémentation efficace parce que
lâcher prise c'est aussi savoir freiner
s'arrêter ne pas céder à l'hyper
activité ambulante freiner pour mieux
accélérer vous savez c'est comme quand
au retour des vacances
après une interruption prolongée tout
d'un coup on a l'impression que les
choses se sont débloquées par magie
freiner c'est aussi prendre du temps ce
que certains appellent perdre du temps
prendre le temps de la rencontre avec
soin de savoir ce qui nous anime ce qui
est vraiment important pour nous est ce
que c'est d'être reconnu pour l'auteur
de cette nouvelle idée de cette nouvelle
méthode ou est ce que c'est de faire
avancer
organisation dans l'entreprise
l'innovation dans l'entreprise freiner
fait aussi prendre le temps de la
rencontre avec les autres du débat
contradictoire je suis surprise comme
souvent l'urgence de la prise de
décision la logique d'efficacité nous
fait oublier cette nécessité
d'alignement freiner c'est aussi prendre
du recul sur les situations les regarder
de plus loin c'est ce que je vis moi
dans mes sessions de co-développement
avec d'autres praticiens systémique on
regarde la situation avec un oeil dans
ce no love d'ethnologue plein de
curiosité et là tout d'un coup on mesure
sa responsabilité et on envisage des
façons de faire différentes
alors je vous rassure je suis remonté
sur mon vélo
mais aujourd'hui j'ai un nouvel outil le
changement de vitesse vous savez ce
changement d'opinion qui au sommet d'une
côte difficile fait que on arrête de
pédaler trop fort on [ __ ] beaucoup
moins fort mais on arrive en haut on n'a
pas besoin de descendre pour pousser son
vélo dans la côte
je vous ai parlé de la situation du
leader de l'innovation mais nous avons
tous des situations que nous aimerions
changer
aujourd'hui nous vivons un changement
d'ère de disruption constante
nous devons nous réinventer en
permanence alors vous aussi vous pouvez
changer de vitesse et je vous transmets
le mode d'emploi que j'ai appris au
cours de ces années
gardez votre cap passé à l'action pour
mieux savoir chercher la différence qui
fait la différence
soyez un bon jardinier et vous verrez
vous pédalerez moins fort pour de
meilleurs résultats
[Applaudissements]